i definitely wanted to talk to you about
ways that
you know
frame versus who you are as a man come
together and how you can get what you
call genuine burning desire which i
agree with um
so when it comes to women
do you think it matters more or which
one holds the larger weight who you are
as a man like handling your fitness your
finances
um
and then obviously you know frame but
which one do you think matters more your
fitness and your finances
and a little bit of game to get the girl
or the fro the overall frame that you
hold in the relationship with the woman
yeah this is like a question that comes
up a lot people say well what's more
important money looks status being
captivating you know
i covered a video on my channel um on
on the seven pillars it's on my podcast
the um you know the unplugged alphas
it's titled on the uh the book
um i think it was the last three weeks
um
i can't say that there's like one or two
that like if you're if you're like a
chad i mean if you're just like badass
good looking like natural good looks
women just throw themselves at you
that's all you need i mean you can be
broke i mean you could be
incarcerated in jail and there's these
women that will actually
letter these dudes in jail and go there
to to bang them right i mean
if i'm not mistaken i think it was mike
tyson i can't i can't remember but it
was somebody famous i'm pretty sure it
was mike mike tyson but
the guard said they basically had a
rotating door at the front of the jail
with women coming in and out to bang
this dude right so it really it really
depends on a number of things but i mean
if you're the average guy you want as
much of all of those things as you know
as you can possibly get so back to the
point earlier where you're talking about
like look you know if you take a good
look at yourself and you're six out of
ten don't even bother with women because
you're gonna be disappointed i mean okay
you might have some success but the
success that you're gonna have is gonna
be with like a four out of ten she's
gonna be so basic you're not going to be
interested in her on a long term basis
or or for anything beyond just like a
hideaway friends with benefits that you
don't even let your friends even know
about sort of thing right because you're
too embarrassed so ideally as a guy if
you want to have a good experience with
women you definitely want to be able to
you know max out on look status frame
money be captivating you know like all
of these things
i completely agree you know one thing
that's kind of in line with what you
said about the pillars i often call it
buckets
because i believe
that an individual i look at it as you
know buckets that can actually fill up
right so if you've got a guy like like i
say all the time i wouldn't cherry paces
with zuckerberg because you can get as
rich as you want but at some point that
money doesn't matter anymore and so you
have to be able to fill these other
buckets up to be able to get
genuine desire across the board because
i don't i don't believe a woman can
truly respect a super super skinny guy
that's
that's not very strong in his frame not
very strong in his presence and it
doesn't matter the amount of money that
he has so filling up each individual
bucket and understanding that you know
you can be super super super fit but
does that last two or three percent of
body fat
really
help you when you could have filled the
money bucket up or the frame bucket up
yeah i like to to like draw this picture
of a wagon wheel you know you know so if
you think of an old-school wagon wheel
that might have like seven spokes on it
you want all of those spokes connecting
from the hub to the wheel
absolutely and if you're short on let's
say two of the spokes and you're like
you know if like a 10 out of 10 is like
a full reach from the hub to the wheel
then you've maxed out everywhere i mean
you're not going to get any better than
that you've got full contact but if
you're missing on two or three the
spokes and they're only like three
quarters of the way up and they don't
actually reach the wheel that wheel is
not going to rotate probably when you
apply pressure and you push it down the
road it's going to sputter and kind of
hop along you might break some of the
other spokes
so a real good way to look at it is try
to try to max out on all them as much as
you can
and then all right cool you know if
you're missing in some areas and work on
that don't don't cry about it don't sulk
over it don't complain other people
don't go looking for reasons why you
should be a victim
double down and you know get the work
done on it that's why when i say you
know just do the work that's what i'm
talking about i shouldn't have to spell
it out for you i shouldn't have to tell
you what the work needs to be be like
how many people have called in on my
show and they're like hey rich how do i
get girls to like message me first and
it's like
dude can we talk about your neckbeard
like what's that all about like are you
trying to make a woman repellent on your
face right oh you know i've been doing
this that and the other thing and it
doesn't really fill in it's like okay so
just get rid of it dude right like like
let's let's work on a look right if you
can't develop a nice you know sliced out
beard that you can get you know dialed
in right then move on from it right
and it's like
okay well you know there's always
something to look at there's always
something to consider but people don't
want people don't want the cold hard
truth man they want rainbows and
butterflies they want comforting lies
they sell way better than the cold hard
truth
absolutely you know one thing we were
talking about before we went on um
which really lines up with what you're
saying right now is there's a lot of
these guys that you know they would
identify themselves as six and i'm
constantly saying okay fine however you
have women that are six
and i i see them all the time in miami
they're in there they're not very pretty
but they're in that [ __ ] squat rack
and will not let me get in the squat
rack until they have until they have
finished their workout these went a lot
of these women are out here fighting
just as hard as men are to be attractive
and these are not as attractive women
and my only thing to a guy that thinks
he's a six is bro you can most likely
get to an eight by handling
your money and your fitness alone
and having a job and and taking care of
your grooming and having a little bit of
style and just trying take a shot oh
seriously i saw a video of yours this
morning because i knew that we were
going to talk and i wanted to catch up
on some of your material because i'm not
super familiar with it i saw this one
you're like dude just take a shower like
smell good like do some basic stuff
bro it's so it's so true man you know
put i mean
maybe maybe don't smoke weed all day or
just it i think it really starts with
like taking accountability for yourself
and knowing that nobody's gonna come
save you yeah and i think i say this
it's one of the most freeing days of
your life is when you realize that
nobody's gonna come save you
and you can kind of look at that and be
kind of cynically smile at it like it's
a good thing because it's so
certain it is yeah that's a great thing
because i saw this on a meme a while ago
and i you know i've distilled this a few
times and it looks like this you get the
guys that are like
nobody cares and they just sulk in it
and then you get the other guys like me
that are like
nobody cares and you just get on with it
sort of thing yeah yeah right so there's
you know there's two different ways to
look at it
absolutely you're dead on
um i wrote something down and i feel
like it'd be a good transition here so
the progression of manhood
and i want to start at the early age
because i think it's important because
there's a lot of young guys that watch
you
and i've been getting a lot of comments
from young guys on my channel so
i think it's important
to identify the hand that you're dealt
especially like what you're talking
about neck beard like whether you have a
beard you don't you're tall you're
skinny you're short you're fat whatever
whatever it is
identify the hand that you're dealt
at a young age and then realize
what you can work on to craft that hand
into a winning hand for yourself which
would tie into your plan to win
what what would you say to that for for
a young man that's really kind of
understanding what's out there in the
world
and then really trying to step out of
himself and evaluate what what hand he
was dealt and and trying to figure out
how to play it or if he should play it
at all
yeah there's
so i call that
i'm getting
sorry i don't know if you guys can hear
it live but i'm hearing feedback it's
bizarre um yeah so i call that
surrendering
and all that really means is
you know you get a guy that's um like
five six
and he's like okay
i'm not gonna be like you can put the
soul inserts in your shoes you know you
can wear certain uh outfits you know you
can comb your hair up an extra inch you
know brush it up and gel it up sort of
thing to get the extra height but you're
only ever going to be that high so you
gotta so you gotta accept it so one of
the stories that i've um told you know
on my channel before is i used to have
this friend you know this roommate
and um we used to call him pocket
hercules because he was about five five
maybe five six you know with the right
shoes on
um
and he used to be like in his early
twenties he used to be like a fat nerd
uh with a bad haircut that was addicted
to drugs and alcohol and he got no
results with women he got tired of that
[ __ ] so he took ownership of his life
and it's one of the reasons why i like
the guy so much is because he did so
much work and i saw the pictures before
and after
and he basically went from like
a pear-shaped nerd with a bad haircut
that looked like a total slob to a chad
i mean he was a five foot five chad
but dude he was a slayer like this guy
got way more women than i did when i was
limited with him now there were some
women that he was getting with that i
wouldn't touch with a
you know with a six foot pole we used to
make fun of him sometimes but he but he
still scored with a lot of hot women too
and it's like he just knew that he had
to max out in every area of his life if
he wanted to do good you know with the
ladies like he knew he was short he knew
it i mean
i'm just under six foot three and he
stood beside me and he like he knew that
he was short there's no question about i
can show you a picture was kind of funny
but um we you know we'd go out together
you know we'd run some game we'd go to
the clubs and stuff like that
and he was always talking he was always
cold approaching
he's always making the effort and he got
results i mean he probably had to work a
lot harder than i did you know if i'm
being honest but um he did the work so
that's part part you know it's the same
thing with guys that lose their hair
right a lot of guys complain oh you know
i get these nerds that call me a bald
seller whatever the hell that is it's
like dude
you haven't like i've had more like i've
had more ass in a toilet seat like you
know you're talking to you dork it's
like oh man and it's like these guys
that are like holding on to scraps or
they're trying to comb it over or like
whatever it is you're trying to do it's
like okay at some point you've got to
surrender to that and just shave your
head because there's a lot of dudes out
there that women pine for rock vin
diesel bruce willis i go right down the
list jason statham i can keep going
sterling cooper barely know the [ __ ]
cooper yeah you know like there's all
these guys out there that look good with
a nice you know shaved head and it's
like if you own it and you're confident
you know with it you're going to do good
with it right
yeah
absolutely man i agree with you and and
that's kind of the point i was trying to
make is like you know
you should look at the hand you're dealt
even when it comes down to style yeah
you know uh andrew's got a shaved head
all right cool so andrew looks like a
[ __ ] mob boss which plays to that bad
boy effect you know whereas tristan
wears suits because he has hair so me
and tristan are wearing suits andrew
looks like he's about to kill somebody
with a leather jacket the whole deal you
know and but
a lot of that is being intelligent
enough to identify the hand you're dealt
you have that beard i can't grow a beard
like that dude i can't like if i try to
look ridiculous
so i don't yeah so you want the facial
hair that like goes with what you can
get right right you want to play the
hand you're dealt to the best ability
that you can a lot of guys wear the
neckbeard thing because they have two
neck two two chins they have a double
chin
so handle the fitness there's a lot of
guys out there i see guys all the time
they will be
you know decent height and i'm looking
at them i'm like man you know it's like
seeing a beautiful woman that's fat
you're like man under there she's really
pretty
and i see guys it's like man he's got
he's got kind of hunter eyes he has good
dimensions you can tell under 40 pounds
of extra fat and that's on him yeah i
mean honestly most most guys evolve to
have hunter eyes because i mean if
you're around today it's because your
mom your grandmother your
great-grandmother they banged somebody
that they thought was the best that they
could do hypergamy right right so the
reason why you exist today is because of
selection and if you're not getting
results today there's something wrong
with something you're doing in your life
for the most part i mean there's some
rare exceptions but for the most part i
mean what's the number what's
like something like three quarters of
the north american population is fat
i mean your looks improved dramatically
just by losing some damn weight
you know
no doubt
you